warrants a criminal referral of former  president Donald J Trump  John Eastman and others for violations  of this statute wow the whole purpose  and obvious effect of Trump's scheme  were to obstruct  influence and impede this official  proceeding the central moment for the  lawful transfer of power in the United  States we all know as we read through  the different  statutes that Jamie Raskin described  there we all know Trump did the stuff  he's accused of we all know that  colloquially speaking he did it but the  question starts to become is there the  possibility of finding guilt Beyond A  Reasonable Doubt here